Andrew Tate hate him why do you hate him
I just think he's misogynistic can you
define misogyny for me
um it's practically like not thinking
that like you're better than women but
thinking that there's like
like in like in general like uh okay so
if you're marrying a man and he's paying
for everything would you like to sort of
be his property and that he'll look
after you the same way he looks after
let's say like his car his house I don't
need somebody to like constantly be like
looking after me I just need some like
if he's my husband like he should love
me but he shouldn't be like feeling like
the need to look after me I'm an
independent person
what if there's somebody dangerous on
the streets that's gonna come attack you
I own pepper spray okay but he's got a
knife and I could get a taser you don't
want a man to protect you in the jungle
out there okay let's say I have like a
scrawny husband like how much is he
really gonna be able to protect me well
you're gonna pick a scrawny man no I'm
not exactly why aren't you gonna pick a
scrawny man because that's just not my
preference but like that is some
people's preference